Sí.
Así que avanzando hacia los bits
y los qubits serán la base computacional del paraíso
con los que podemos abordar
problemas complejos en el mundo
así que intentemos entender la diferencia entre ellos
y de dónde surge el poder de los qubits
si miramos el lado izquierdo
es una forma de describir y vamos a usar estos diagramas
a lo largo de la presentación para
mostrar el poder: estamos viendo un círculo
y dos puntos; cuando el punto está en el polo norte
eso es el cero, y cuando está en el polo sur es un uno
eso es el bit clásico de dos estados. Ahora, un qubit es la
unidad de información en el mundo cuántico
y aquí nos quedamos con la imagen
como una esfera de cero y uno
y podemos tenerlos en este estado de superposición
tenemos un truco especial que está disponible para nosotros
no solo podemos posicionarlos en esta esfera
sino imagina que cada uno de estos
es como una pequeña luna
que está en la esfera y podemos rotar la luna
así que aquí estás viendo que
la esfera inferior ha sido rotada ligeramente
por eso ves un poco de azul
y rosa, y podríamos rotarla completamente
así que esto es un giro de ciento ochenta grados
entonces tenemos esta noción de fase que lo cuántico nos otorga
tres superpoderes que se exhiben en los qubits
son los poderes de la superposición
el poder de la interferencia
y el poder del entrelazamiento
así que exploremos esos: el principio de superposición es en realidad
bastante sencillo de entender
así que la estrella en el lado izquierdo
estamos en polo norte cero o polo sur uno
y si sumamos esos dos estados
ahora tenemos un qubit en superposición que tiene tanto
cero como uno simultáneamente: norte
y sur. Ahora el diagrama de la derecha es lo mismo
pero ahora vamos a hacer un pequeño truco
vamos a aplicar un gate, un gate cuántico
en lo que hicimos aquí, recuerda
podemos cambiar, ahora podemos
rotar estas pequeñas lunas, ¿verdad?
así que la hemos rotado cien
y ochenta grados y ahora tenemos un uno
así que cuando hacemos la suma de cero más uno terminamos
con un estado de superposición
pero nota que es diferente
y el de la izquierda tenemos
todavía cero y uno pero ahora con un estado rotado
para el uno, y eso va a ser muy poderoso
para luego aprovechar una segunda cosa realmente interesante que es
el principio de interferencia
y esta no es una operación que podemos realizar en el mundo clásico
de los bits, así que aquí en este ejemplo tenemos
un cero y uno en la izquierda más
este nuevo estado que creamos
que también es cero y uno
pero con esta luna rotada; cuando hacemos esto ahora
podemos interferir esos dos estados
y nota algo realmente interesante que ocurrió
hemos cancelado el estado uno
y hemos terminado con el estado cero
lo hicimos porque interferimos los estados
así que la siguiente oportunidad que tenemos ahora mismo
es cuántos estados podemos crear
y lo hermoso de lo cuántico es que podemos crear un número exponencial
de estados, así que miremos un sistema que tiene
cinco qubits; en este caso estamos representando estos qubits
como qubits independientes, ¿verdad? Los estás viendo en la izquierda
ceros y unos y se están multiplicando, tenemos cinco
de ellos, así que el número de estados que podemos crear en un
computador cuántico representado en la esfera a la derecha
es dos elevado a la
cantidad de qubits que tenemos; en este caso son cinco
así que dos elevado a la cinco son treinta y dos estados
así que estamos viendo treinta y dos de esas pequeñas lunas
nota que en este caso no incorporamos
ninguna fase, todas son rosas; el aspecto poderoso de
usar esta propiedad llamada entrelazamiento en el mundo cuántico
es que podemos crear ahora estados
como el representado a la derecha
donde tenemos estas combinaciones de rosa
y azul, donde ese estado no puede ser descrito
como el producto independiente de
estos cinco qubits; en este caso
dado que tenemos treinta y dos estados
lo que esto nos dice es algo realmente profundo